hello everyone like the title suggests
this is one of my favorite Fischer games
in this game Fischer plays a wonderful
game but the finishing blow he delivers
comes with such brutality and yet with
such elegance and the game was played in
1960 in the Leipzig Olympia is playing
against Rene little Ian Martin and mr.
Rene was a international master from
Chile his greatest achievement was
probably in 1954 when he won the UNESCO
tournament in Montevideo ahead of Aussie
Bernstein and Miguel Nidal I oh no
Miguel my Dorf
and some of you may remember or see
Bernstein from my video up I did a video
on him about three months ago how he
escaped the firing squad they were
executing prisoners and when his name
popped up at the commander in charge
recognized the name was it Bernstein and
he asked argued a great chess master he
replied yes I am and the commander
requested the de play a game and if he
wins he gets to keep his life but I mean
this story is present pretty much
everywhere III as hard as I tried I
couldn't find the game they played
probably due to the fact that this never
happened or maybe Bernstein never
decided to publish the game but I would
be very interested to see what does one
play when when his life is on the line
but ok story aside mr. Rene has the
white pieces and he plays he plays d4
now we have Knight to f6 c4 g6 the Kings
Indian defense Knight to c3 Bishop to g7
e4 and Fisher castles and this is a this
is a standard position in the Kings
Indian White has a lot of options here
he can go Bishop e2 he can go Knight of
3 some play h3 some play a3 even f3 was
played but when I first started playing
the Kings Indian defense I checked out a
couple of games couple of famous games
and studied a couple of lines but
whenever I had this position over the
board for example in a classical game in
a tournament and I had the black pieces
I always thought
what if what if white pushes 'if I've
here what do i do then then I always
thought that I messed something up in
the opening maybe I forgot to play d6 or
something why would I allow me 5 here
and what do I do with my knight do I go
do I really go to age 5 or 8 so this
travelled me for quite a while when I
first started playing the King's Indian
and that's why I really enjoyed this
game because in this game white really
does push he 5 and this is something you
don't see very often what when a white
plays against the Kings Indian official
replies Knight to e8 after the game they
asked Fischer what he thought about the
movie 5 and Fischer only replied weak
but it's it's not like it's a mistake or
anything it's just that it gives the
black a lot of a lot of options to gain
activity F for fish plays d6 Bishop to
e3 and c5 seemingly offering a pawn if D
captures D captures then Bishop captures
and c5 wins a pawn
so D captures on c5 by mr. na and now
Fischer plays Knight to c6 disregarding
this pawn
so what do you do here well you do have
to capture upon it is the strongest move
as Fischer allows it C captures on the
six official place each capture son d6
and Knight to e4 now capturing the pawn
doesn't really give white anything if
you capture Knight capture some b6 and
this is this is excellent for black your
Bishop is stranded there are only three
rook to e8 is coming Fischer would enjoy
this position very much so instead after
each capture 76 94 by mr. Oren a bishop
to f5 and here white could capture the
pawn on d6 but instead Knight the g3 was
played if you capture Knight capture Sun
b6 after Knight captures Queen captures
Queen captures he captures on d6
you get this night to be four move now
threatening night to see to check for
King the rook forking the bishop and
after you defend this with something
like rook to d1 you still get a knight
to c2
after King moves Knight captures King
captures and Bishop capture some b2 and
okay white is up upon but black has a
really active bishop pair and the works
are ready to jump into the game so this
this is definitely compensates for that
one pawn and obviously mr. Renee agreed
with this since after Bishop to have
five he played night to g3 Bishop to e6
now Fischer doesn't want to allow that
night to capture the bishop Knight to f3
developing and Queen to c7 and here
there are a lot of options available for
white definitely black is better here
but what white should have played is
something like f5 not developing with
Bishop to d3 but better better yet
immediately pushing f5 and after G
captures an f5 now Bishop to d3 with
tempo and black is still better but at
least white is doing something instead
after this Queen to c7 move by Fischer
Renee played Queen to be one it's a it's
a weird move to do your King is still
anyone
you still haven't developed anything and
the plain Queen to be one it seems like
it's preparing f5 also may be protecting
the B to pawn but on the other hand
you're blocking your rook the rook can't
come into the game and you still haven't
developed anything so first replace D
captures on e5 and ranae continues with
his plan he prepared at 5 so he will
push her 5f5 Fischer ignores the pawn he
pushes his own born efore and what do
you do here well F captures on e6 was
played if you play Knight captures on e4
you get Bishop captures on f5 this spins
the Queen and after E for if you capture
with the Queen you get Bishop captures
on b2 with an attack on the rook after
rook b1g captures on f5 attacking the
Queen and after Queen to c2 Bishop goes
back to g7 and well again your king is
still an e1 black is perfectly fine
those bishops are monsters and at the
end of this variation white is in
a pawn so not really something to look
forward to
so after E for Rene Tridev captures on
e6 we have it captures on f3 g captures
on f3 you don't want to capture the f7
pawn you'll just open up blacks F file
so G captures on f3 and here facial
plays f5 not capturing on e6 but better
yet f5 with the threat of f4 so
fisheries inviting Renee to push FF for
himself and this is exactly what Renee
does f4 and now that night that was
stranded on e8 comes into the game and
is very active Knight to f6 now with
ideas of Knight to e4 and Knight to g4
Bishop to e2 or White has to develop
quickly and get that King out of the
center rook F to e8 enough going for
that pawn on e6 and well now Fischer
will enjoy the e-file or all for himself
and is preparing to double up rooks came
to f2 not castling pistol wants the King
to protect the bishop on e3 rook
captures on e6 we have rook to e1 now
preparing to move the bishops so he can
counter Fisher's double the rooks on the
e-file rook 88 now Fischer doubled up on
the e-file and Fischer's position is
amazing here doesn't really matter what
white plays black will win this game but
white played Bishop to f3 what ideas of
activating the bishop now Bishop moves
like Bishop to d2 are possible
exchanging both of the rooks on the file
that Fischer has placed but here comes
Fischer's brutal but elegant finisher
Fischer plays rook captures on e3 and
when you look at this move you think
okay what's the idea
rook captures on e3 Fischer plays rook
captures on e3 and well believe it or
not this rook is so poisonous that this
is probably the most poisonous rook that
that ever
stroll the
file but mr. Rene doesn't believe
Fischer so he captures it King captures
Rokan III and I invite you to find
Fisher's idea here there are a lot of
moves that come to mind but one is one
is what makes this game so great
I'll give it a couple of seconds if you
want to pause the video or something or
just to enjoy this position so okay if
any of you found the move I congratulate
you you are you're a great player and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
Fisher's mastery in this position
Fischer played Queen captures on f4
would check so I mean it's such an
elegant move and it's so brutal in this
position of course Rennie resigned the
game as he saw that there is no coming
back from this
the initial idea of course is if King
captures Queen then the simple basic to
h6 is checkmate the King has nowhere to
go
the knight is guarding g4 and E for this
Knight is guarding he five and the
bishop is covering III so all the escape
squares around the King are covered and
if you don't capture if after Queen
captures on f4 if you play something
like King to d3 or or King to d2 and
allow life to capture a bishop then of
course you're losing the game I mean you
lost a piece and your King is on the run
so let's see a line where where the King
tries to defend the bishop for example
King to f2 if King to have two then
Knight to g4 check King to g2 not nice
to e3 check on only square where you can
protect the bishop is f2 so King to f2
and now Knight comes to d4 and white is
without a move there is no defense
against Queen captures Bishop on f3
white is getting checkmated you there
there is no way a white can stop this
and I mean he can play Queen d1 to give
up the Queen but that would be just
silly
so after Queen captures on f4 Rene
agreed that this is enough for this game
this is moved 23 so definitely a
miniature and quite a lovely one at that
so yeah one of my favorite Fischer games
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Daniel drily and armino database
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here as yesterday was Todd's
birthday both of the videos will be
about doll so you know they're under
nice games do check them out if you
haven't
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon and yeah I almost forgot
thank you everyone for for joining my
stream yesterday we I had almost 700
viewers alive and there were 320 people
participating in the tournament so quite
a quite a tournament I mean I it's
announced the tournament some 20 minutes
before it began so 320 people is is huge
so thank you all for first joining the
tournament and to everyone who
participated and especially to the
winners thank you for watching I will
see you soon